what drove us to do this is we saw
suicide rates were going in the wrong
direction
we need to make a change and it's our
job and our duty as
you know as parents and as members of
this community
to take a hard look at this and do
whatever we can to make you know make
the change
i hear a lot of people say you're not
unique no you are that you are
ladies and gentlemen we have kate and
marisa in the house
from straight up impact which is an
awesome company i just recently
discovered i love the mission so here i
wrote it down
to create commercial films to move
audiences to create
social change i love it
welcome aboard ladies thanks for having
us
yeah so so you've got a new film out
called mackenzie i saw just the one
minute
trailer i guess that you have on your
website or it's about this
girl who's trying to keep it all
together
trying to keep her 4.0 gpa and swimming
and extracurriculars and
is kind of on the edge of of making it
versus falling apart
uh why was this the film that that you
chose to make
this is a series so it's a series
the first film of the three-part series
so
film it's all addresses epidemic issues
that are contributing to anxiety
depression and suicide
so we've identified three of them the
first one is the education systems
and and the pressure cooker that these
kids are under that has
driven some suicide and
the second is over prescription of
medication and the third is how we use
social media
so it's an overall what drove us to do
this is we saw suicide rates were going
in the wrong direction
and you know we saw a big change from
when we were in school to
what these kids are going through and um
too many children medicated i mean it
was disturbing us we're mothers
and so this has been myself maurice and
our partner pam roy this has been our
passion is to
not just call out the system but to
bring in additional resources
so that we're not trying to take
anything down but we're building
something else
we also pretty much wanted these kids we
interviewed
so many and they're really struggling
they're really struggling
um in a very um industrialized
system of education and pharmaceuticals
and social media and their widgets for
profit
and we wanted to really give them a
voice
give them an opportunity to tell their
stories and
hopefully we as a community of educators
and policy makers will
actually listen to them because as kate
said you know
suicide is at an epidemic level it's the
second
leading cause of death means
and that's and it's under-reported yeah
so
clearly the numbers are higher than that
and
we need to make a change and it's our
job and our duty as
you know as parents and as members of
this community
to take a hard look at this and do
whatever we can to make you know make
the change
are there any recommendations in the
film of what that change
actually is well i'm not sure if you're
familiar with the book man search for
meaning by victor frankl
but we're actually making the film with
tony robbins which is
awesome nice that's gonna be epic when
is that coming out
so well we we we are in in development
phase we're in the scriptwriting phase
cool working with the franco family and
specifically
we're working with alex wesley frankel
who's victor franco's grandson he's also
a licensed logo therapist so a
missing piece that we don't talk about
when it comes to mental health is the
actual health part
and finding meaning and purpose and you
know viktor frankl helped eradicate the
suicide rate
in the 20s by helping people find
meaning and purpose in their life he
actually got the rate down to zero
and it seems that from what we've heard
on the kids we're interviewing
is that there is a perception that
there's
they're unclear about what there is to
live for
choices are being made for them they're
doing things and they don't know why
i mean the way in which the system is
constructed is treating more
children like widgets than people
individuals
so i hear a lot of people say you're not
unique no you are
that you are not not any one of us is
made up exactly the same
so we're talking about meaning and
purpose so when you just to answer your
question
that's not something that's brought up a
lot when you discuss mental health
um there's not really a class in school
around meaning or purpose either
right it's about taking the math skills
yeah it's interesting because you're
hitting people
at that age where they're struggling to
become an adult
you know it's like they're they're maybe
you know still living at home
but trying to figure out what's my place
in the world i don't want to just listen
to what my parents
uh say i maybe don't want the life that
they have but i don't know what the
alternative it is
and so i love that you're trying to
approach it from uh
hey this is what's happening you're not
alone
lots of people are going through this
you don't feel like you have to suffer
in silence which i think is
another big deal like we're afraid to
say that we're struggling
uh and nobody like we look at instagram
and see people's perfect lives and
realize
we feel like we suck because we are not
getting all this stuff but really
most people aren't happy and so i love
that you're kind of shedding the light
on this
is the goal then to say hey like find
your purpose
find your meaning figure out why you're
doing what you're doing like is that the
next step that people should be taking
to get out of it
it's more what did i just say this is
more of a thing first i think first step
is
you say so many people are suffering so
many people are suffering i mean this is
a deep
it's a problem that we can't just go to
our knees
and say hey i feel terrible
or i'm depressed or we can't go next
door that we speak to somebody in the
grocery store there's no community
there's i
hope it's more isolation and to start
talking about it that nobody's alone
so many people feel like this and how we
we don't we shouldn't have to call an
800 number we should be able to talk to
each other everybody's
suffering and there as viktor frankl
said everyone
has their own auschwitz like we so i
think it's
build communities and starting this
discussion and then yeah
just talk about meaning and purpose i
mean it's it's a deep question it's not
like
this is a very it's a process
i also think looking at the education
film
first um which mackenzie was so brave to
just come on and really tell her
personal story and these are short films
as well and you know
as filmmakers we really wanted to drive
in on the emotional side of the
storytelling
because it's where you can really move
people when you get them
caught up in the emotion of somebody's
personal journey
but you know we we are operating in
a very kind of industrialized school
system
that values a kid's worth based on a
number
based on their gpa based on their sat
score
and in subjects that they may not
necessarily feel passionate about
and so those that don't necessarily
thrive
in test taking and don't necessarily
thrive in mathematics or english
are not getting valued as a human being
and they're because it's just based on
this point system
so a lot of what we're exploring here is
like how do we focus on more on
student-centered learning or asset-based
learning and giving kids
kind of the freedom and and the okay to
follow their passions lean into stuff
that they feel
just more drawn to more passionate about
and um
you know for my son who you know he's a
musician
and he struggled immensely
in the in the teaching process and you
know being diagnosed immediately with
adhd
and being you know you know being pulled
out of class being put in a rocking
chair like trying to treat him
you know as though there was something
wrong with him when he's really just a
brilliant kid that
was more drawn to music and art and
film than he was towards mathematics and
it's really for us as parents to look at
what our kids are passionate about and
give them the
way to lean into that absolutely
back to the point around community are
you are you trying to create
like are you having a facebook group
around it are you trying to create
community
yourself for straight up impact you're
gonna connect to other community groups
like what's the community plan well so
we're
just launching this is our launch launch
so yes we will be starting
groups yes we we will be creating
resources and we'll be sending out
newsletters and we will be updating
people but we're at the very
infancy stages of our life and what we
wanted to do is start
the conversation the best way to do that
is through an emotional experience
and listen from the kids perspective not
the adults but listen from the child
and her voice is really powerful and um
and but we are creating things now so if
you sign up you can hear more about it
there you go and it's what straight dash
up dash impact.com
yes yeah yeah that's cool so i do i
wasn't sure if i'm watching a trailer if
it was a true story or not so it's cool
that that's actually
her and it's not you know some scripted
thing
um how does how does she feel about
being
the face for this is it extra pressure
is it relieving how does that
impact her i mean she's scared for sure
i mean to be
vulnerable and you know but at the same
time she's so wise she's so smart there
is a hopeful side of it
and she's an actor you know she's an
advocate an advocate and she's
she sees that this mission is beyond
herself
and she hopes that her own suffering
will help other people
how could you pick this age group
to target um
probably from personal experience
okay of what you know we've been through
our backgrounds and that's sort of the
age that
you're still a lot of times not heard
misunderstood nobody's listening you
know it's it's a tough age it's tough
hormonally
of pressure wise social economic i mean
it's just
it's a it's a an age that needs a lot of
support
and um and so we picked that age i
remember
some of personal things which is why
i've been wanting to do this for a long
time
is there a difference in gender
at all for this or age group or issues
that people are going through or you
think it just hits everybody
that's what we love about it is it
doesn't discriminate at all
we've seen it i mean at so many
different types of people and even ages
ranging from 12
to college years i mean it
it it spans quite far unfortunately and
so
yeah it's i have not seen it
discriminate this this
this topic is hard for everybody and we
you know we
have talked to kids all over the country
yeah and due to covet we were restricted
obviously from from a filmmaking
perspective to stay in california but
the goal for this
is to branch out and tell stories from
all across the country and turn this
into an ongoing series right now it's a
three-part series
but our goal is to give kids a voice
from
all parts of the country and the world
and the world yeah what what advice
would you have for somebody who's
struggling with it and
and their parents are their big problems
that there's expectations
you're supposed to go do this you have
to keep the family business
or you've got to go be a doctor and the
kids
want to be a painter or something you
know just like something totally outside
they want to be a film you're crazy to
be a film producer
go don't go make movies go be an
accountant right
for the kids who want to pursue their
dreams if they've got
expectations inside the family that
doesn't support that
what do you what do you recommend
i mean it is a family issue right it's
uh
a lot of times we want to change the kid
but it's the fam
it's the environment that needs to be
focused on
so you know i don't know how to change a
parent's
mind that needs a child to be something
that they don't want to be
which is why we are making
films where you can actually hypnotize
people influence people where they watch
something and they have an emotional
experience and it sparks a conversation
and maybe a parent watches that
because there's kids who've committed
suicide and maybe a parent watches that
and says oh my god
let me ask my kids some questions am i
doing the right
thing maybe they are i don't know but
first i think you have to expose it and
then talk about it
in a way that's not shaming or
judgmental or
you know everyone's well meaning for the
most part
anybody wrong but maybe looking at
something differently
we had on one of our we had a intern
that of mackenzie and her mother was on
set with us
as well and her mother had no
idea that this young girl was feeling
the way
that she was feeling identical to what
what mackenzie was experiencing
and she's a senior and getting ready to
go into college and she that is not a
path that she wanted to take
and she didn't have the bravery at that
point or even
the knowledge that there's that there
are other choices and she ended up
having
like finally having this conversation
with her parents about that
that there's a new path for her she
wants to explore something outside of
this
very traditional college or high school
to college to
grad school or whatever that pathway is
and they
had a conversation it was the first time
that she felt
safe enough and free enough to say hey
my path is not your path and it was
amazing because
kids i think kids have a hard time
sharing
you know sharing what what they want to
do outside of what this very traditional
pathway has been for so many years i
don't think they know what they want
lord not even just sharing you didn't
knowing
i've had so many kids what do you nobody
knows i want to play video games
yeah that's what i want to make that's
what my son
what i love about it is i think if a if
a kid in that age group
is struggling with it but they don't
know how to broach the conversation
with their parents what they could say
is hey
go watch mackenzie and you're
it's like the entry point to even start
a conversation
is that part of the intention of
conversation
to give kids a voice to really try to
come together to create a tangible
change
in the system that's broken and if it
wasn't broken then kids wouldn't be
killing themselves at an exponential
level
you know what i love sir ken robinson's
quote because he's a big advocate for
this who says
you know people ask how do we stop them
because responses stop creating and i
like
it's that simple i mean it's not that
simple but that it is that simple
it's not easy but it's simple the person
comes to mind
is after parents have watched his video
or the kids have watched this video
that then one immediately they feel not
alone which is great i mean i'm not by
myself i'm not isolated
there's other people who look like me in
the world who are struggling with this
exact same thing so that already can
make
people feel more connected if people are
then going to have
a conversation with the people whose
opinion that they care the most about
typically probably their parents do you
have a
i almost see it like as a one-pager like
here sit down with your parents and
and talk about these three things or
these five questions
like as a next steps like okay i watch
the movie
yes i feel not alone i'm inspired i need
to go have that tough conversation
i don't know how to have that tough
conversation how do i sit down and what
do i
ask and what do i say or how do we
create a safe space
i think people still like is there a
resource guide or like five questions to
talk about with your parents or
like what's the next step after well i
mean it's not a one-size-fits-all for
everybody but we will definitely these
are part of our creating resources and
these are things that we will be
building soon um but these are the kinds
of questions that people ask i don't
know
that there's a one size one because i
mean i come from a certain kind of
family you couldn't talk to my parents
the way you talk to
you know our colleagues parents very
different so it depends
um hopefully resources that can help
people
find their meaning and purpose and
follow that
yeah i mean i love it i think it's a
starting point for conversation
i think the more you can kind of give
people the tools uh
to then continue the conversation either
within your community of
like-minded people which is awesome or
with the people whose opinions they care
the most about
i think that's how we start to start
making meaningful change
yes yeah yeah and it's not going to fix
overnight i mean
but we have to start looking at the
things we can change instead of the
things we can't
some people in the comments are asking
about cultural differences oh yeah
i mean california i'm sure you hit a
bunch of different cultures mackenzie
you know comes from one background but
i'm sure there's
you've done research and you've
connected with people from all sorts of
backgrounds
does he well first off the problem is
everywhere right the problem is not just
this is not just a
lower class upper class middle class
white brown anything right i mean it
hits
teens from every right eliminate it
crosses all socioeconomic communities
and all kids and each struggle you know
is their own and personal to them and
that's why for us to give
these kids an opportunity to to speak
to hear like let their voices be heard
let that let let them know that their
voices are valued
they're worthwhile that we want to hear
from them
there there are people that want to hear
their friends what they're the
the res out there and we want to be um
one build out resources but also
be a place where they can have a voice
if they you know
we're we're here straight up impact is a
place
that they can share their stories and
we're calling for them too
like as if anybody's listening we're
looking for more
yeah more subjects yeah yeah
looking for people that are interested
in sharing their story and being
being a part of this overall campaign
i love it so so we've got i mean this
instagram live which is great straight
up impact.com if you want to check it
out uh for people who watch the youtube
replay we'll we'll put that link in the
description below go check it out if
somebody's watching this
in six months 12 months 18 months from
now obviously the movie's already come
out
is the best place for them to go still
straight up impact
well we'll have it on youtube channel
then it'll also be on our website
i mean the ultimate goal is obviously to
have a big movement around this but we
have to start with a like our small
launch or quasi-small launch yeah
and then build from there and just build
um
more followers and more stories
and more content around this
and then and what's in the pipeline and
so you got this is a three-part series
is this one
there's medication
yeah the over-prescribing medication to
children
right and what was the third one um the
misuse of social media
um and the isolation of social media
so those are the three that we're doing
right now
and then yes and then we mainly make
feature films feature length feature
films this isn't this is just a part of
our
business that we find in probably most
important
the most important work yeah i love it
and then main searcher meeting is coming
out
in 2022 or when's that when's the winter
release date
next we'll be filming next year cool
well
super exciting keep me posted i want to
learn more
i'm i'm pumped about this new release
mckenzie's episode one right in the
three-part series
yeah so mckenzie's episode one straight
dash up dash
impact uh again the link is here pinned
or check it out in the comments below on
youtube
uh i love i love what you ladies are up
to as soon as i saw it come across
her desk i saw the mission to create
social change to
i was like i love it we got to have them
on we got to talk about it
i'm looking forward to future
conversations as well and
um best of luck with the launch i think
what you're doing is really important
and
the more i can lend you know my little
spotlight on things as well it'd be
amazing
and we love everything you're doing as
well yeah definitely tuning in all the
time you always have the best guests on
and um you're awesome so thank you
thank you amazing well this is the first
i've done a
two-person one where they kind of squish
together the camera so
i love it i love it well thank you
ladies have a great week and thank you
for spending some time with us to talk
about mackenzie and stayed up impact
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with lisa bill you check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there part of my own personal mission is
to break the idea that women
should be any right you should be an
entrepreneur you should be a mother at
the end of the day it
really is what do you want to be